[Music]
teen titans go to the movies is almost
here the cast critics and journalists
you've already seen the film have
revealed a couple of secrets that have a
super excited watch until the end to
find out what essential item Carrie
Peyton who play cyborg says you have to
bring when you go see the movie if
you're new to the things channel hit
that notification bell see you never
miss our new videos and click that
thumbs up button if you dig Teen Titans
go as much as we do here are the 10
secrets hidden in Teen Titans go to the
movies Nicolas Cage finally gets to be
Superman this is a major big deal for
fans who have always wanted to see
Nicolas Cage finally playing Superman
now this is a major big deal for fans
who have always wanted to see Nicolas
Cage finally playing Superman apparently
in the 90s during the Tim Burton's
superhero movie era Nic Cage was all set
to star as Superman he even did a screen
test with a Superman costume the movie
was called Superman lives but the film
never made it to production fans were
totally obsessed with this movie it was
set to be a story about how alienated
and alone
Superman / Clark Kent felt among the
humans on earth it portrayed him as a
loner who was blessed with superpowers
this feeling of isolation is something
most humans can relate to and therein
lies the irony the one thing that
divides Superman from the mortals is the
one thing that could actually help him
relate to and understand the mortals
sadly Studio politics prevented the film
from ever being made but the makers of
Teen Titans go to the movies wanted to
give Nick Cage his chance to finally
play the role of Superman this is a
major big deal you guys it's literally
the role he's always wanted to play he
even named his son after Superman's
Kryptonian name kal-el fans are totally
stoked mind-control this summer there
seems to be a running theme in superhero
films Lane control if you haven't
watched incredible stew yet here's your
warning
spoiler alert ahead okay the villain in
Incredibles - screensaver is a sinister
character is trying to dominate the
world by using video technology to
control the minds of humans and
superheroes alike screen slavers
monologue points to the battle between
technology and mind saying that
superheroes are part of our brainless
desire to replace
experience with simulation screens labor
said every meaningful experience must be
packaged and delivered to us to watch at
a distance so that we can remain
sheltered and ravenous consumers in the
teen titans go to the movies trailer it
looks like Slade is controlling the
minds of the masses - even as
superheroes if you've seen Incredibles -
that scene of hypnotized superheroes
might look pretty familiar so why all
this mind-control talk in the movies
maybe it's because every bit of
technology is competing for space and
ultimately a bit of control over our
minds from fake news to social media to
trolls and BOTS on the internet that
cause us to fight and divide ourselves
it seems the battles of our future are
gonna be battles of the mind they're not
going easy on DC Teen Titans go to the
movies are taking a lot of jabs at the
DC superheroes and movies and it's
actually pretty hilarious
the Titans make fun of DC over and over
again in the trailer and that's just the
trailer imagine how many more jokes will
turn up in the actual film there's a
super funny bit when the Titans run into
Slade their would-be arch-nemesis may
mistake Slade for Deadpool Slade gets
super annoyed and laments at the fact
that everybody thinks he's Deadpool
Slade says that Deadpool should be the
one saying that he is not Slade because
he came out way before Deadpool no I'm
pretty sure you're Deadpool this was a
total lol moment for the fans and then
there's the part of the trailer where
Starfire asks the Green Lantern if they
made a movie about him he says they did
we don't talk about it thick burn and
they totally poke fun at all the Batman
movies that have been made and then
there's the first ttg movie trailer
where they're all dressed up like Wonder
Woman this is because many people are
saying that Wonder Woman is the best DC
movie that's been made in the wild they
really give it to the DC Universe in
this movie and we can't stop laughing
the anti heroes it seems that the
superhero movie genre is taking a turn
in a new direction the direction of the
antihero we've seen it with Deadpool
Rorschach and now Teen Titans go the ttg
movie even got their own Justice League
type movie poster you know that Justice
League poster with all the superheroes
on it it says you can't save the world
alone well Teen Titans go to the movies
had
a poster that parodies that famous
Justice League poster it seems like
people might be getting tired of the
cookie cutter superhero movie that we've
seen so much of audiences are looking
for something different and movies like
Deadpool and Teen Titans go to the
movies are like a breath of fresh air
for moviegoers these anti heroes are
flawed just like us they can be selfish
foolish Petty and childish and it's
hilarious to watch it kind of makes
sense just because someone has
superpowers doesn't mean they're
naturally endowed with virtuous moral
and noble qualities and ttg certainly
seems to deliver on the childish front
did you guys see the 15 second bodily
function joke in the trailer they're
calling this movie the superhero movie
to end all superhero movies hopefully
bring a diaper to the movie
speaking of potty humor Carey Peyton who
placed the role of cyborg in the TV show
and the new movie shared a pretty juicy
tidbit about what to expect from the
movie he's telling audiences to bring
one essential item with them during his
visit to the Chicago Comic and
Entertainment Expo Carrie Payton said
fans need to bring a diaper with them
because they'll wet their pants
he thinks fans are gonna laugh so hard
at the hilarity on the big screen Peyton
kept joking by saying he's wet his own
game several times when he's seen the
movie he said he had to take several
trips to the outlet mall because his
jeans were all soaked
he said it's awful because he's a grown
man and can't figure out why it keeps
happening he's hoping the third time he
sees it he'll be able to keep it
together but all joking aside Carrie
Payton talked about how excited he is
about the film
he said that Teen Titans go to the
movies is gonna be good stuff but yeah
about that pants wedding stuff um
oversharing much the ttg movie might
revive the original Teen Titans show
many fans of the original Teen Titans
animated show are mad that the show got
canceled and replaced with Teen Titans
go fans were upset with the immature
humor that seemed to make fun of the
original characters back when they took
themselves so seriously as a matter of
fact some comic book fans don't like it
that the show and subsequent movie makes
so much fun of the DC characters they
know and love one fan even took a screen
shot from Teen Titans go and redrew it
in the original Teen Titans style poly
reposted her
but art on Twitter Tara Strong saw
Holly's drawing and posted a message to
this hardcore Teen Titans fan she posted
but just so they all know at a movie
session they had recently they told her
that if the Teen Titans go movie kicks
all the butts they would do the show at
the same time as season six she
encouraged the fans to go see the movie
even if they hate Teen Titans go so as
it turns out the Teen Titans go movie
might actually benefit Teen Titans fans
too it might just be the right time for
fans to come together so everyone wins
surprise cameo so it's clear that the
ttg movie has an all-star cast not only
do they have the original voice
characters of the ttg Kane the movie
snagged the talents of Will Arnett who
also signed on as a producer fans
already know and love his voice from the
Lego Batman movies I'm a night stalking
crime-fighting vigilante Jimmy Kimmel is
voicing the role of Batman then there's
the heavy hitter Kristen Bell she plays
the role of the big-time movie director
who rejects the Titans when they
approached her to make a movie about
them we've already established that
Nicolas Cage is playing his dream role
of Superman but in addition to these
exciting stars who are lending their
vocal talents to the movie there may be
a few surprises for audiences movie
critic Scott Menzel tweeted that the
movie was a total blast and currently
his favorite animated film of the year
he wrote that he loved all the
references from the obscure superheroes
to the eighties music then he shared
that there's even a surprise cameo that
will be sure to generate huge laughs
from all um we are seriously freaking
out over here who could it be
will it be Deadpool Argus is Deadpool
who do you think it'll be obscure DC
superhero references this part is gonna
have the true DC fans so excited we
noticed that in the trailer there are a
lot of movie posters on the wall at the
theater people who know about the film
say it is packed the brim with Easter
eggs referring to the DC Universe we've
already seen references to Batman
Superman Wonder Woman the Green Lantern
and Aquaman but there was also an
appearance by the atom on the wall
there's a poster of the challengers of
the unknown and also detective chimp in
the case of the missing mustache the
yes in that poster is in the shape of
the Superman logo comics and pop-culture
journalist meg Downey tweeted about the
Teen Titans go movies she saw it she
posted that the movie rule but she
doesn't think that's really a surprise
she added that there's a prolonged
challengers of the unknown joke that had
her rolling that seems to indicate that
this movie is packed with Easter eggs
and funny jokes about DC heroes of the
past it may be one of those things that
only the dedicated DC fans get but we're
sure that this movie has got enough
humor and entertainment to satisfy
everyone which cult comedy gold ladies
and gentlemen funny gags we've uncovered
some teasers from Teen Titans go to the
movies that reveal way more funny
moments than the two trailers for
example one teaser has a great running
joke about all the Batman movies that
have been made in the beginning of the
teaser the Titans pull up to a movie
theater that is lit up with bat-signal
shining pictures of Batman and the Joker
and just totaled Batman overkill when
they get inside they see a trailer Robin
thinks this might be the one about him
it starts by saying every great
superhero needs a great movie Robin is
beaming with excitement
then it's revealed that they're talking
about the Batmobile cyborg points out
that even the car gets a movie before
Robin does then there's a scene where
Batman is chasing the game as they try
to get away in a car Starfire is
shooting a Batman but he keeps
reemerging he announces his return each
time with the actual title of a Batman
movie he jumps out of an explosion
yelling Batman Returns and then he does
it again
saying Batman Forever Starfire says what
we're all thinking after the last run of
Batman flicks there is no stopping the
Batman the atom gags are hilarious to
Jayde Wilson fan Theory so there's a
pretty interesting theory about the
Titans heavily sought after nemesis
Slade the roundtable analyst the trailer
of the Teen Titans go to the movies and
had a couple of cool ideas about the
direction the film might take there's a
completely new character in the film who
goes by the name Jade Wilson which
sounds a lot like Slade Wilson in the
ttg movie Jade is a film director who
rejects the Titans by saying she only
makes films about real superheroes but
if you notice her white hair and pale
skin you'd probably make the connection
to Rose Wilson aka ravager and daughter
slate ravager has already made an
appearance in Teen Titans go so it's
possible that the movie director Jade is
Rosa's mother which would mean that
she's intimately connected with Slade
now and make her rejection of the Titans
all a part of a sinister plot to keep
them invisible to the rest of the world
not to mention the Titans are trying to
get Slade to be their arch-nemesis so
who is Jade if Kristen Bell is playing
the role she must have a pretty
significant part in the film we'll just
have to wait and see and those are ten
secrets hidden in Teen Titans go to the
movies thanks for watching
[Music]